das dschungelbuch stellt jeden
filmemacher vor eine große
herausforderung denn es ist ja ein stoff
in dem tiere und menschen direkt
miteinander interagieren indirekter
körperlicher nähe und zwar ein kind mit
einer menge von tieren in einem urwald
das kann man wie im alten trickfilm
durch zeichnungen
er kann das aber auch jetzt durch
technologie lösen dass manche dinge echt
sind
der schauspieler die natur und manche
dinge am computer erzeugt werden die
tiere die sprechenden tiere und weiters
wird so fugenlos miteinander verarbeitet
dass man einen komplett illusionären
eindruck hat einer komplett echten welt
beziehungsweise einer komplett erfunden
welt denn man kann in diesem film nicht
mehr unterscheiden was echt ist und was
falsch
unten ist
wo du auch ihn liest wie sie dich auch
nennen du bist auf alle zeit mainz noch
im grunde genommen handelt sich um eine
art jungen kleinen james bond den
bürgern der ganze film seine einzige
verfolgung wenig momente in diesem film
in dem es scherze gibt in dem ein wenig
entspannung er verfolgt mich ausruhen
kann ich dem der film wirkt nicht um den
zuschauer der film will den zuschauer in
beschlag nehmen
ich würde zögern kleinen kindern
ich persönlich weil es doch eigentlich
nur ab verbreitet und größe es gibt
unglaubliche szenen mit riesiger
geschwindigkeit wie gesagt riesige hafen
ist unglaubliche szenen mit riesiger
geschwindigkeit licht in riesige hafen
wird überall dreck tiger selbst ist eine
erweiterung niederträchtige bestie
nennen mich in eine abfolge von
wahrnehmungs schocks und diesem film
insofern ist es eigentlich ein film für
einen schon etwas älteres publikum
eine abfolge von planet schule insofern
ist eigentlich eher ein film für einen
schon etwas älter was ist das
die fährte die ich bitte ich habe den
film mit der faszination und dem man sie
sehen sehr auch so etwas nicht gefasst
war
ich habe in los angeles sehen im sinne
fährt dich dass er einen viel stoff zum
nachdenken gibt außer das staunen eben
über diesen über diese unfassbare
technik die offenbar inzwischen möglich
so viel zu bringen dies ist kein film
über den man sehr lange reden kann sie
insofern sehr lange nach der halb nach
als eine art wahrnehmung experiment am
publikum im abspann werden ungefähr 600
computer ingenieure genannt die für das
ganze verantwortlich sind
insofern beeindruckt das aber auf der
ebene der erzählung würde ich den
trickfilm und das buch empfehlen kaum
verlor computer ingenieure genannte
verantwortet herr beeindruckt dass ich
helfe aber auf der bühne der
erzählerischen jung ist bin ich mensch
und menschen sind verboten